Evet Merhabalar Hoş geldiniz Şeref
verdiniz
bu Hiranur
çok heyecanlandı
esasında O beni takdim edecekti
küçük bir antrenmanda yaptı ama burada
salonun coşkusu onu çok heyecanlandırdı
ve takdim edemedi ama belki daha sonra
takdim edebilir değil mi Mira
şimdi
Bugün size hiranur'un hikayesini
anlatmak istiyorum
ama Hikaye Böyle başlamadı
malumunuz hayatımıza bazı güzellikler
sıkıntı kapısından girerler bir
sıkıntıyı görürüz Ama onun ardındaki
güzelliği göremeyiz işte böyle bir
sıkıntı ile başlayan güzelliği anlatmak
isterim
10 yıl kadar önce Bakü'de çok başarılı
Sayın kadınla da beraber galiba Sayın
Yıldız da vardı önemli bir toplantının
dönüşünde geberede bir toplantımız vardı
yüksekçe stratejik hiçbiri toplantısı
Bakü'den uçağa vereceğiz çok başarılı
bir toplantı ve tam uçağa binecekken
eşim telefon açtı dedi ki sana üzücü bir
haberim var Hayırdır dedim
münevverin çocuğu Down sendromiymiş dedi
Münevver büyük kızım ikinci çocuğuna
hamile Beş aylık hamile ve
Down sendromlu
doktorum
Tabii Doktor olarak Down Sendromu
biliyorum tanıyorum
ama açık söyleyeyim Dede olarak daha
önce tanışmamışım itiraf edeyim
hiçbiriyle tek bir satır konuşmamıştım
daha sonra dediğimiz zaman ufak tefek
seve Sen Güleç yüzü hareketleri kendine
özgü sevimli bireyler Ama tabi Sonuçta
bir engelli birey
onun
şokuyla Uçağa bindim yanımdaki
arkadaşımla konuşmadan yani daha doğrusu
konuşamadan 3 saatlik yolculuğu bitirdik
hemen uçaktan indim evime gitmeden eşim
de evden kızımın evinde buluştuk
ve
kızım Tabii allak bullak gidiyor geliyor
5 aylık hamile ve Down Sendromu bebek
Tabii 10 gün kadar karar verme aşaması
geçirdik Ben Tıp doktoruyum ama erişkin
doktoruyum
çocuk ve kadın doğum uzmanlarının
meğerse Kadim bir problemiymiş Kadim bir
tartışma engelli bir çocuğa hamile
kadın doğrusunu doğurmasını doktorların
bir kısmı doğursun Çünkü iyi bir
eğitimle çocuklar sevimli bir birey
haline gelebilir diyor
bir kısmı da hayır doğurmasın
Zira engelli birey ailenin diğer
fertlerin huzuru ile ilgili sıkıntı
oluşturabilir diyor kararı kızıma
bıraktık
o ara Tabii Doktorlar dışında da konuyu
Duyanlar bize tavsiyelerde bulunuyorlar
en ilginç tavsiyeyi Lokman ayvadan
duydum Lokman ayva
İstanbul Milletvekili olarak da görev
yap çok değerli bir dostum Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi mezunu inanılmaz Zeki görme
engelli ama
yazdıkları konuştuklarına falan baksanız
asla görmen gelir filan demezsiniz
Lokman bey dedi ki hocam dedi
kararınız sizin tabii ama dedi Şöyle bir
düşünün Çocuğunuz normal doğdu
birinci günde kucağınızda tutuyorsunuz
bir anda düşürdünüz çocuk başını çarptı
engelli oldu Ne yapacaksınız
Tabii ben bunu kızıma söylemedim
o anda bir şey düşündüm daha sonra kızım
dedi ki baba dedi Allah'ın takdiri
başımın üzerine ben de doğuracağım o
zaman dedim uçakta gelirken düşündüğüm
ama daha sonra Lokman bey ile de
konuştuktan sonra kararlaştırdığın fikri
ve eşimle konuştum Annenle konuştuk
Eşini de al beraber bunu konuşacağız ve
teklifimizi yaptık
biz bu çocuğa evlatlık olarak talibiz
Yani hem torunumuz hem çocuğumuz olarak
büyüteceğiz Madem doğurmaya karar verdin
şiddetle karşı çıktı hem Damadım Hem
kızım ve dedi ki biz dedi çocuğu
kendimiz büyüteceğiz Nitekim çocuk tam 1
Ocak
2013'te doğdu Hacettepe'de Serdar
hocamız
yardımcı oldu
ona minnet borçluyuz hakiki 1 Ocak
doğumlu
tabi Down sendromlu
2 ay sonra ameliyat oldu ama 2 ay sonra
ameliyat olurceye kadar da
yoğun bakımlarda süreçler geçti sonra 2
ay sonra da yine Hacettepe'de Metin
Demirci hocamız gerçekten şükranlarımı
arz ediyorum
ameliyatını yaptı %30 ölüm riski olan
bir ameliyattı
ve sonra
tabi yoğun bakımda da birkaç ay daha
kaldı ve çıktı
bir defa Oradaki herkese çok minnet
borçluyum Hani Esra Hanım dedi ya niye
Hacettepe tetiksiz konuşmasında
Ankara'nın direktörü konuşuyor ortak bir
noktamız var ortak noktamız hiranır
Ankara Üniversitesi Hacettepe arasında
çok bağımız var Ankara Üniversitesi'ne
Rektörü İhsan Doğramacı hocamız aynı
zamanda hacettepe'nin de kurucusu yani
hacettepe'nin kurulmasında Ankara
Üniversitesi'nin çok rolü var ama
Hacettepe ile Ankara Üniversitesi
arasında önemli bağlarımızdan bir tanesi
de hiranur'dur
o ara Tabii yoğun bakımda yoğun bir
süreç geçiyor Geçenlerde kısma dedim ki
O günlerden aklında ne kaldı
bana dedi ki
ya dedi bak yani bakımdan tedaviden
ilgiden fevkalade memnundum ama dedi bir
cümleyi hiç unutamıyorum nedir dedim
unutamadığım cümle
bir çalışan
bir arkadaş şunu söylüyor diyor ki
gidiyor geliyor tabii emziriyor hirai
Münevver Hanım diyor isterseniz çocuğa
fazla bağlanmayın Çünkü her an her şey
olabilir Bir anda diyor ikinci defa
yıkıldım
esasında burada o arkadaşımızın kötü
niyetli olduğunu asla düşünmüyorum o da
yani çocuğu kaybederse fazla üzülmesin
diye Muhtemelen ona telkinde bulunuyor
ama değil o kadar önemli bir şey ki her
şeyi iktisatta kullanmak lazım
kelimeleri cümleleri dili de iktisatı
kullanmak lazım
Bu benim kendime yazdığım bir söz
daha önceki bir hadiseden dolayı yani
hiç kimse üzerine alınmasın dili
dikkatli kullanmazsak Hakikaten o bizi
çok zor durumda bırakabiliyor Bunu da
daha önceki bir hadiseye yönelik olarak
yazdığı bir söz ah be dilim tutamazsam
seni edersin beni Dilim dilim gerçekten
dil fevkalade
önemli Onu çok dikkatli tutmak lazım
tabi bir yandan Hiranur büyüyor her
anını yakından takip ediyoruz Ben aynı
zamanda Babayım 3 çocuğum var çocuklarım
kusura bakmasın ama ömrümün son 20 yılı
çocuklarımın büyüdüğünü görememenin
üzüntüsüyle Takip ettiğim yatırımları
büyük yatırımların büyüdüğünün
sevinci arasında geçtiği için onları
maalesef ihmal ettik onlar kusura
bakmasın ama hiranur'un her bir anını
takip ettik Yani hepimizin var
kardeşleri var Çocuk yediği zaman
duyduğu zaman gördüğü zaman seviniyor
muyuz ama hiranur'un a görüyormuş a
duyuyormuş a konuşuyormuş a adım
atıyormuş a yürüyormuş filan derken her
bir anını takip ediyoruz Tabii yürüme
derken bu konuşmayı yaparken aklıma
rahmetli Sakıp Sabancı'nın bir serzenişi
gelir onu mutlaka biliyorsunuz ama 32
günde rahmetli Mehmet Ali Birand'ın
programında bir serzenişi vardı
27 yaşında daha bir tane ayakkabı
almamışım daha Çünkü hiç göremem
rahmetli Sabancı Metin sabancı'ya
ayakkabı alamadığını otomobil
alamadığını sercanişle bir duygusallıkla
ifade eder parası olmadığı için hayır
imkanları çok fazlaydı otomobil
fabrikası kurdu ayakkabı alabilecekti
Ama onun hüznüyle Hep yaşadı ve
Sabancı bu
programda bir şey daha söyler
Özal'ın arkadaşı eski tarım ve
bayındırlık müsteşarı Muammer dolmacı
Beyefendinin şöyle dediğini söyler der
ki; Ağam Allah sana bunu bilinçli verdi
Çünkü çok fazla Metin Sabancı var Onlara
imkanlarını harcayacaksın der Nitekim
sabancı'da o imkanlarını fazlasıyla
yapmaya çalışır ve oradan Aslında
kendisine bir ders çıkartır ve o dersle
çok önemli şeyler yapar e sıkıntılar da
öyle değil midir sıkıntıyı bir avantaja
çevirebilirsiniz benden önce konuşan çok
değerli konuşmacılarda onları ifade etti
İşte Sabancı'nın Metin Sabancı adına
inşasında
tadilatında çok büyük katkısı olan
Baltalimanı Devlet Hastanesi'nde böyle
bir şeydir onunla ilgili bir anekdot
hatırıma geldi onlar da sizinle
paylaşmak isterim bu Bir Temmuz 2003
tarihinde
Başbakanımızın ve sağlık bakanımızın da
katıldığı bir tören yan yana oturuyoruz
Tabii Sabancı çok espritüel birisi
rahmetli
sabancı'ya dedim ki Sakıp abi dedim ben
sağlık müsteşarıyım Peki oralı olmadı
Ben Adanalıyım dedim malumunuz Adana ile
çok büyük bağlantısı var kayseri'dedir
ama yine Peki oralı olmadı bu ara
konuşmalar devam ediyor sağlık
hizmetleri ile ilgili galiba
Başbakanımızın böyle övgü dolu bir
ifadesi olunca bana sağlıkla ilgili bir
şey söyleme ihtiyacı hissetti Ben de
cebimden kağıt kalem hiç eksik olmaz ama
Kağıt bulamadım kalemim var
bir peçete aldım ve peçetenin üzerine
sağlıktan bahsettiği için şöyle bir şey
yazdın dedim ki Ağam dedim sağlık
bakanlığını biliyorsunuz dedim biliyorum
dedi yazdım aslında dedim sizin de ortak
nokta çok fazla bu sağlığa daha fazla
yatırım yapmanız lazım Benim gayem
birazcık daha sağlık için yatırımı
teşvik etmek dedim bak ortak noktamız bu
dedim
bunu görünce
bir anda farklı açtı elimden tuttu
Ya ben seni çok sevdim dedi Allah sizi
inandırsın bir buçuk saat hiç bırakmadı
elime ve
[Kahkaha]
hiç bırakmadı
sonra anladım ki meğerse bu onun ince
damarıymış o damarıyı bulmuşuz ve Sakıp
Ağa tabi imkanlarını hep iyi yönde
kullandı En azından Baltalimanı
Hastanesi için söyleyebilirim orada çok
fazla desteğini gördük ama imkan kadar
değerli arkadaşlar imkanı doğru
kullanmak da önemli yani imkanı bazen
aşırı kullandığınız zaman takım
sıkıntılarda beraberinde gelebilir
Ben Tıp doktoruyum demiştim endokrin
uzmanıyım
doçentlik yıllarımda iki tane Hasta
geldi kadın Hasta özel muayene fişi
kesmişler Efendim dediler Biz özel
muayene olmak istiyoruz Tamam baktım
tetkik tedavi dedim ki 6 ay sonra
geleceksiniz
gittiler 15 gün sonra baktım İki hanım
yine ellerinde özel muayene fişi tekrar
geldiler dedim ki hayırdır ya hocam Biz
seni çok sevdik tedavinden de çok memnun
Kaldık biz bir daha geldik Ben fişi
aldım arkasına iade yazacağım
paranıza yazık Dedim dediler ki bizim
kurumumuz özelleşti
özelleşen kurum özel muayene fişlerinde
ödüyor o zaman dedim kurumuzun parasına
yazık dedim iade ederken tam böyle
uzattım Ama dedim bugün Sizde çok önemli
bir hastalık da hissettim
bir anda renkleri kaçtı Hayırdır bir 10
saniye falan Durdum dedim ki sizde imkan
hastalığı var imkan hastalığı tedavisi
çok zordur imkan hastalığı olanlar
istediği doktora istediği hastaneye
istediği sıklıkta istediği zaman
gidebilme imkanıdır bunlar hiç
iyileşmezler dedim
ve sonra fişi verdim Tabii imkan
hastalığı deyince rahatlatan onlar Acaba
bir kanser filan mı diye düşündüler o
Hanımlar iyileştim bilmiyorum imkan
hastalığına ama imkan hastalığı çok
yaygın da bir hastalık hakikaten ondan
da kurtulmak lazım O yüzden
imkan büyüktür dersin ama gün gelir
imkan yüktür demek zorunda kalırsın
imkanı da doğru kullanmak gerekir Fakat
ben imkandan daha büyük olan bir şeye
İnanıyorum o da İşbirliği ve
dayanışmadır
bize dayanışmanın ne kadar önemli
olduğunu gösteren çok önemli bir deneyim
oldu
dayanışmaya hakikaten son derece önemli
Türkiye belki imkanları daha büyük olan
ülkelerden iyi bir dayanışma ile çok
daha büyük başarıyla çıktı Onun için
başta sağlık çalışanların olmak üzere
cumhurbaşkanımızdan en ücra köşede
bulunan vatandaşlarımıza kadar hepsine
ayrı ayrı teşekkür borçlarımız
olduğunuzda ifade etmek isterim
Bu benim
en çok sevdiğim kelime burada benim
çalışma arkadaşlarım da var Onlara sık
sık da ifade ediyorum mütemmim kelimesi
de aslında
İşbirliği ve dayanışmayı çok iyi
karşılayan bir kelime
mütemmüm birbirini tamamlayan demek
Geçenlerde dedi ki Hacettepe
koordinatörleri
Sayın Gazi Huri ve Sayın Ayşe Beyza
Ünüvar Bana davetiye takvim için
geldikleri zaman bu kelimeyi hatırladım
Çünkü orada diyordu ki eksik parçamızı
tamamlamak ister misiniz diye bana
soruyorlar konuşmacı olarak ve hakikaten
Hepimizin bir eksik parçası var Ve bunu
tamamlamamız gerekiyor ve bu hakikaten
son derece önemli
Körling sporunu belki salonda yapanlar
vardır Ben yapmadım ama Körling sporunu
spor olarak seviyorum ama
dayanışmayı ve işbirliğini ifade babında
çok daha fazla seviyorum ya bir Spordan
daha öte bir spor gerçekten
körling'e baktığınız zaman bir granit
taş
iki kişi süpürge ile onu hedefe doğru
götürüyor daha sonra Hedef noktasında da
diğer arkadaşlara ona yardım ediyor
esasında Hayatımızın her bir noktası
böyle kendi rolümüzü iyi çerçeveler ve
iyi bir şekilde organize edersek
Esasında Çok daha büyük şeyleri başarma
şansına sahibiz bakın tam çizgide
bırakacak diğer iki kişi süpürgeyle
burun denilen süpürge ile hedefe
ulaşmasını sağlayacak Körling sporu bize
İşbirliği ve dayanışmanın önemini ve bir
konuda başarmanın anahtarını veren çok
önemli bir spor Ama tabii burada bakınız
5-6 kişilik bir ekip var ama
ekibi kurmak kadar
ekibi ritmi de önemli O yüzden kim
kurmak yetmez ritim de gerekir yani o
timle ritmi buluşturmazsanız asla
başarıyı da yakalamanız mümkün olmaz
[Alkış]
İranlı benim tek torunum değil Benim 3
tane daha torunum var 4 Torun sahibiyim
Zeynep Ayşe beyruha ve Asaf Zeki
her birinin ayrı karakteri var ve her
birinin ayrı bir tadı var ama ortak
özellikleri bana dünyanın en güzel
sıfatlarından dedelik sıfatını
kazandırmaları hakikaten Onların her
birine ayrı ayrı görüyorum ve Hiçbiri de
mukayese etmiyorum bir bilimsel veri
değil içimizde Tıp doktorları var
bilimsel anlamda açıklaması nedir
bilmiyorum ama bir dede ve baba olarak
tespitim şudur çocuğu bir başkasıyla
kıyaslamak mukayese etmek onlara
mutsuzluğun kapısını açan bir anahtar
oluyor o yüzden bu kaise yapmamak lazım
ve biz de hiç hiranur'u hiç kimseyle
mukayese o kendi kategorisinin
önemli Asli bir bireyi her bir çocuk
öyle ama Hiranur tamamen böyle
genellikle Hiranur ve benzeri çocuklarla
ilgili hep böyle mukayese yapma eğilimi
vardır hiç Biz bunu bu gayese etmedik
onu da ifade etmek isterim bu benim bu
güne kadar aldığım en güzel tebrik
mektubu
Bu da dinlediğim en güzel marş
[Müzik]
bende böyleyim size dudak en son ocak
abiler O benim
yazısı bana çok O benimdir o benim
Pek beğeneceğim
Evet
maverdinin muhteşem bir sözüyle bitirmek
isterim
bulduğunuz şeyin değeri onu ararken sarf
ettiğiniz Emek kadardır Emeğiniz bol
olsun Çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]